mais je pense c'était sur un ciel c'est
du B justement qu'on entend de ces gens
là parce que si on ne va pas les voir si
on essaye pas de comprendre aussi ce qui
est ce qui les anime je pense qu'on
manque complètement le bateau au niveau
d'une couverture parce que c'est une une
proportion assez importante de la
population américaine qui pense qui
effectivement le racisme ce n'est pas
grave l'avortement de toute façon c'est
pas notre problème et les armes à feu
ils font en avoir davantage parce que ça
prend toujours ça prend plus pour se
défendre je pense que ce qui est
important de noter c'est que évidemment
toute cette espèce de c'est surtout des
extrémistes aussi et on est quand même
dans un dans l'univers de la la Poste
vérité là et donc on a cette
polarisation qui qui vraiment anime ces
gens là et notre rôle à nous c'est
évidemment de refléter les différentes
pensées mais ultimement le journaliste
si un me dit que il y a mille soleil
dehors et l'autre il me dit il pleut des
cordes moi mon rôle c'est de dire de
sortir par la fenêtre de regarder je
m'excuse il pleut il y a pas de soleil
donc il faut quand même remettre ça en
perspective malgré tout tout en en
prenant le pou quand même de ces gens-là
on n'est pas là pour leur faire changer
d'opinion c'est pas possible ils sont
comme ça il y a parfois ils l'ont
doctrinement parfois c'est des
mouvements très bien organisés mais nous
en tant que journaliste
on connaît la haine des médias notamment
de l'action comment il vous voit
c'est sûr que depuis 2016 quand Donald
Trump a pris le pouvoir c'est sûr que ça
a beaucoup changé parce que lui a ouvert
les vannes justement de on peut dire
n'importe quoi on peut faire n'importe
quoi fake news milliards vous êtes
l'ennemi du peuple c'est sûr que nous
quand on va sur le terrain dès qu'on
voit une caméra à you fake news etc donc
c'est sûr qu'on l'entend tout le temps
mais en même temps je veux dire on fait
notre travail on dit mais non on peut
vous parler on va vous écouter mais
arrêtez de partir du principe on va
forcément mentir oui non c'est ça c'est
très il y a vraiment une radicalisation
nous quand on fait par exemple des
sujets sur l'avortement ou s'il y a la
religion aussi qui entre en compte et
souvent c'est extrêmement émotif donc tu
peux pas vraiment raisonner mais je
pense que le public pour nous je pense
dans nos reportage on est obligé
d'équilibrer les opinions faut montrer
toutes les opinions et le public est
capable de se faire sa propre opinion je
sais qu'une fois on a couvert justement
un rassemblement puis on a disciple ici
on est de CBC puis quelqu'un dit Oh
great vous êtes de Christine brocassis
on n'a rien dit on a dit
[Rires]
qu'on s'en serait pas Sandy aussi donc
il y a plus il y a quand même de
l'idéologie là-dedans mais ce qui se vit
aux États-Unis la montée du populisme ça
a changé la façon de travailler la pose
vérité et tout ça mais ça ça c'est
contagieux comment ça se vit quand vous
êtes sur le terrain
Raphaël ben moi j'ai été aux États-Unis
quelques années pendant justement la
présidence de Donald Trump donc j'ai
découvert plusieurs de ces
rassemblements je dois dire aussi que
quand même quand on est canadien on a un
accès sans être représentant de la
question broadcasting on a un accès qui
est assez bon les gens sont ouverts à
nous parler parce que cette polarisation
elle est beaucoup au niveau des médias
américains une grande un des médias
américains c'est peut-être un peu moins
le cas à l'endroit des médias canadiens
ça c'est un avantage dont on dispose sur
le terrain maintenant je suis en Europe
et on voit cette polarisation qui existe
aussi dans les sociétés européennes
par exemple faire des reportages dans le
cadre d'élection en Hongrie réélection
de Victor Hormann et le sentiment que
j'avais c'était un peu de me retrouver
dans un rassemblement de Donald Trump
quand on couvrait les partisans de
Victor urban il y avait beaucoup de
similitudes dans le titre de propos
qu'on entendait et là d'ailleurs ça m'a
pas été très favorable d'être
représentant d'un média canadien parce
que quelqu'un n'aimait pas du tout le
Canada et ses politiques il est venu
clairement me le dire donc français
c'est un peu différent des États-Unis
mais on voit cette division là puis on
la voit ailleurs en Europe par exemple
prenez le Royaume-Uni ou le débat sur le
brexit il est toujours présent et il
divise beaucoup la société c'est le
regret du brexit
un peu pour certains mais quand on parle
de polarisation il y a des pots de
discussions qui sont parfois des
discussions de de sourd de gens qui ne
s'entendent pas sur cette question du
brexit et ça ça rappelle aussi ce qu'on
voit aux États-Unis entre démocrates et
républicains l'équilibre de la parole
certainement parce que si on ne parle
pas aux gens qui appuient le brexit
comment on peut voir venir ce mouvement
qui finalement s'est concrétisé c'est
essentiel je pense ah ben l'exportation
de la polarisation à l'échelle de la
planète est vraiment incroyable et j'ai
découvert un sujet qui est absolument
rien à voir avec la situation aux
États-Unis ou en Europe j'ai été sur une
petite île un archipel tout près de de
la Chine qui appartient sur un
territoire taïwanais on voulait
démontrer que c'est pas blanc ou noir
ces tensions là entre la Chine et et
Taïwan qu'il y a des gens qui ont des
attachements à la chaîne même s'ils sont
taïwanais et il y a des gens qui ont vu
le reportage et on est dans cet esprit
là de polarisation ou tout doit être
d'un côté ou l'autre et on me reprochait
d'avoir été trop nuancé d'avoir
admis qu'en fait il y a plus qu'une
situation plus qu'une vérité dans ce
cas-là donc c'est vraiment l'état
d'esprit dans lequel on est de toute
façon générale et les gens qui me le
disaient étaient des gens qui venaient
d'ici du Canada qui avait vu le
reportage
tout le monde a un peu tout dit je
dirais le match conclurai simplement en
rappelant que notre rôle à nous c'est
jamais de juger les gens à qui on parle
mais de les écouter pour pouvoir
refléter ces idées parce qu'elles
existent ça ne sert à rien de se mettre
la tête dans le sable et je pense qu'on
offre un portrait beaucoup plus complet
de ce qui se passe autour de nous quand
on donne la parole à tout le monde sans
nécessairement cautionner c'est pas ce
que l'on fait on n'a pas à dire que
c'est bien ou pas
c'est dur à entendre on connaît les
vérités mais on n'est pas là pour juger
on a eu pour écouter c'est important de
montrer que ces gens-là existent parce
que dans le cas de la Russie si on vit
dans un monde de propagande ou c'est pas
une exception mais plutôt la règle ça
fait partie de la réalité du pays qu'on
couvre ici on ne comprend pas les gens
qui nous entourent on peut pas faire un
métier comme il faut si je peux rajouter
juste une petite chose aux États-Unis ce
qui est très dur aussi c'est les réseaux
de télévision c'est Fox News contre CNN
et quand vous écoutez Fox News qui
répètent tout le temps la même chose il
parle du Grand remplacement que les
États-Unis vont être envahis par des
migrants donc les gens finissent par se
radicaliser et il y a énormément de
mensonges qui sont diffusés à la
télévision et ça radicalise une partie
de la population et je pense que il y a
un rôle des médias aussi sur sur toutes
ces radicalisation de la population le
la seule fois où finalement on disait
qu'on était canadien puis on nous aimait
bien il me dit là vous avez vos
camionneurs Canadiens bravo
mais abandonné la question je la
laissais un peu plus tôt est-ce que les
gens vous perçoivent comme des méchants
socialistes communistes comme ou le
prolongement de la politique canadienne
Frédéric oui évidemment à travers les
réseaux sociaux à travers les énormes
commentaires qu'on reçoit souvent oui
énormément et puis
oui mais c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on parlait de l'exportation
justement de la polarisation et c'est
comme si les personnes qui qui nous
suivent et décident de nous envoyer des
e-mails de bêtises des des messages sur
les réseaux sociaux on regarde un peu et
c'est exactement comme si c'était
perroquet de ce qu'on entend aux
États-Unis ce qui écoute Tucker Carson
sur Fox News donc c'est toujours un peu
les mêmes termes qui reviennent et qui
oui c'est ça et donc on retrouve partout
donc c'est c'est ça qui est quand même
incroyable parfois inquiétant parce que
parfois c'est assez violent aussi
et et donc je veux dire l'idée derrière
ça c'est de ne pas engager parce que
encore une fois on n'est pas là pour
pour les convaincre de quoi que ce soit
je veux dire ces gens là en général ne
changent pas d'idées et continue leur
leur chemin vers justement ce qu'ils
pensent être la vérité et au fur et à
mesure de répéter leurs mensonges des
fois où les faussés quelque part qui
colportent ils pensent que ça devient
une vérité que les gens les vont les
croire ils vont les suivre davantage ça
révèle l'importance de couvrir ces
pays-là ces situations là on l'a vu
correctement avec le Brésil il est
important de rapporter ce qui se passe